PETE LEPAGE: Well
hello, everyone.
My name is Pete LePage.
And I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And today we're going to be
talking more about using great
tools for building mobile
web applications.
Last week, some of you may have
joined me for a special
Chrome Developer Tools session,
Mobile Developer
Tools session, where we talked
about some of the really neat
tools that you can use,
like libraries and
other stuff like that.
This week, we're going to talk
about testing and emulation
and other great tools that
you'll find will help you to
build great mobile
applications.
So like I said, welcome.
So last week--
the link to the slides
is there.
There's the Development
Environments stuff that we
talked about, the Authoring
Framework stuff, as well as
some of the libraries.
This week, it's the Testing and
Iteration Flow and some
Performance Tooling.
If you're looking for some other
great tools, Paul Irish
has a great session on the
Tooling and Web App
Development stack that
you can check out.
And these slides will
be available
after the fact as well.
If you want to go and follow
along or ask questions as
we're going, the link is there
at the bottom, right here.
Well, I guess it is not quite
highlighting for me right now.
But you can see the link
at the very bottom.
If you have questions, you
want to post those.
Feel free to go post your
questions as we move along.
And I'll take your questions
as we go and at
the end of the session.
So let's jump in and talk about
some testing tools and
ways that you can better test
and see how your environment
works when you're building
mobile web applications.
So one of the first things I
want to talk about is the
network link conditioners and
really sort of understanding
how you can better understand
and better test the
experiences that you're getting,
when your users are
experiencing their websites
on a mobile device.
Because on a mobile device,
you can't always count on
having a 3G connection.
Sometimes it may be Edge.
Sometimes, it may be Wi-Fi.
Sometimes that Wi-Fi may be
worse than a 3G connection.
Sometimes it may be
really spotty.
Sometimes it may not
exist at all.
So there are some great tools
that are available for testing
on your mobile device.
There's two that I think are
really interesting--
Charles Proxy, which
is available there.
It's available for the PC, for
the Mac, and for Linux.
So you can install
it on whatever
platform you're using.
And it will go and basically
proxy all the network
connections.
So all the requests that
are going through go
through that proxy.
And you can specify how
you want it to behave.
The other one that's pretty
interesting is the Network
Link Conditioner.
And this is a Mac tool.
This is something that you need
to get through the Apple
developer tools.
So when you install Xcode,
you can get it there.
And the Network Link Conditioner
is installed in
your system settings.
Let me bring it up here.
So I'll bring up my tools,
my System Preferences.
And down here at the bottom, you
can see this Network Link
Conditioner.
So when I start the Network
Link Conditioner, I have a
couple of options that
I can choose from.
I can choose the profile
and whether I want to
turn it on or off.
So first off, let's
go and turn it on.
But let's turn it on for an
Edge Good Connectivity.
So if I do this, you
can see a couple of
things get set by default.
It limits the bandwidth that my
device can connect to the
network with.
So I no longer have the full
network bandwidth available.
I only have a 256K
kilobit stream.
Also, I'm not going to
drop any packets.
But it's going at 350
millisecond delay to all of my
requests on the downlink.
On the uplink, it's going to put
in 200K connection speed
and a delay of about
370 milliseconds.
So by turning that stuff on,
it's going to slow your
network connection down.
It's going to cause some
pretty slow things.
So I'm going to bring up my
website because I know my
website is probably not exactly
designed for a slow
connection-- so petelepage.com.
And you'll notice it takes
a little while for
stuff to come in.
And it takes that extra time.
So basically, what it's doing
is pruning down my network.
It's making my pipe smaller,
so to speak.
So that way you can get a
better idea of how your
network is going to behave
under low bandwidth
connections.
It's a really good way of
testing and understanding.
Through here, you could
also go in.
And you can set things like hey,
I want to see what a LASI
network is going to look like.
So notice here, we've got 1%
packet dropped and a 440
millisecond delay.
I guess it really helps
to turn this guy on.
So I'm going to go ahead
and turn this on.
I have to enter in
my password, so
turn my password on.
Let's just make sure I
got turned on here--
on.
So now, petelepage.com--
I guess I didn't get
it on earlier.
So now, let's see how long
this takes to load.
Again, much slower, so
before, we saw it
load reasonably fast.
Now, we're still waiting
for content come down.
We don't have that section
on the right.
So I can see that the important
content on my
personal website comes
up pretty quickly.
The thing that I want people to
be able to see here, on the
Thinking About, comes
up pretty quick.
But the other content is going
to take a while to load.
When the Network Conditioner
is running, you've got this
little guy up here telling you,
hey, it's up and running.
And so you can bring it up
really easily, if you
want to change it.
If you want to go and say, hey,
I'm on 3G or whatever,
you can turn that on and off
pretty quickly-- really
easily, without having to go
fight through lots of stuff.
It's a good tool to be able
to use and understand.
Charles Proxy is a really
powerful as well.
Charles Proxy-- one of the great
things about it is it'll
do all of your network
connections.
And it gives you a lot more
inspection ability.
So you can go in and see
what's going on with a
particular request.
You could take one specific
request and
make it take forever.
So you drop one specific
request, if you're doing a lot
of XHR requests or something
to that effect.
It's a good way to be able
to specify some of
those things in there.
On Android, if you want
to do this on a
phone or on a tablet.
You can do it on a phone
or tablet as well.
On Android, you can set up
the proxy to go through a
particular device.
So it's kind of buried
in there.
I'll get a blog post out or
something up on the Chrome
developers page in the next day
or so, to talk about that.
But you can go in, and you can
turn that proxy on, so that
you can actually use that.
Under iOS 6, if you have the
developer tools turned on, you
can turn on the Network Link
Conditioner in there as well.
So that you can see how the
network conditioner works on
that particular device.
You can test it, again, in
a specific scenario, to
understand how things are going
to work, how they're
going to behave.
So let's go ahead and close
that and go back
to our slides here.
So faking it with the Network
Link Conditioner is just one
way that you can understand how
your app is going to work
for your users, who may not be
connecting with the same great
bandwidth that you're
connecting with.
One of the next things I want
to talk about is some of the
developer tools within Chrome.
Because Chrome offers a lot of
great tools to help you test
your web application.
And I call it faking it
because it provides an
emulation experience.
It's not going to be a true
experience because you're not
running on the same hardware.
The processor on my Chrome OS
machine or on my Mac or
anything like that is obviously
much faster than it
is on my phone or tablet.
But at least I can be able
to go, understand
what's going on.
And I can get a pretty
good sense of how
these things are working.
So there's a couple of things
that you can do in the Chrome
Developer Tools.
So I'm going to bring up the
Chrome Developer Tools now, so
that we can see what's
going on here.
So I've got the developer
tools up.
And I'm going to click on this
little guy here in the bottom,
the little gears icon
for the settings.
When I bring up the settings,
if I go to Overrides, I can
change a number of
Chrome settings.
So first off, I can change
my user agent.
So I can fake out to my server
what browser I'm running as.
So I could say, hey, I'm running
as an iPhone iOS 4.
And so sure enough, it shows
here what my user agent is.
You can see it showing
up there.
But it also automatically turns
on the device metrics.
Now this is one of those things
that I think is really
powerful and really, really
useful to web developers.
Because what it does is sets the
screen resolution to the
same screen resolution
that I would get if
I was on that device.
So in this particular case,
it's got 640 by 960.
So it's setting my screen
resolution to the right size.
It turns on a font-scale factor,
whether it's going to
scale my fonts or not.
So you've got the
device metrics.
So you can see what
your experience is
going to look like--
much easier to do this than it
is to resize your browser.
I'm sure everybody has done it
here before, where you try and
resize your browser down to
exactly the right size.
And getting it to that
particular size you want is
just a pain in the butt.
So this is a good way to be able
to go in and say, hey, I
need a particular screen size.
So sure enough, there's
the screen size.
You can see these things are
rendering as I expected it.
One of the next things that you
can do is overriding the
geolocation position.
So you can fake out to the
browser where you are.
If you want to say, hey
look, I'm in New York.
Or I'm in Mountain View.
Or I want to go test
something.
You can go in, and you can
specify the latitude here and
the longitude here.
So that you can say, hey, this
is where I am right now.
I want to just take my word for
it that this is where I
am, in case you're doing any
kind of geolocation testing.
And you can also say, in
particular, I want to emulate
a particular position.
So I want to say emulate
position unavailable, which
may happen, maybe, if you're
in a nice cement room where
you can get a location.
Or maybe just the user chooses
not to provide a device
location, going in and being
able to specify exactly the
location or whether the location
is not available--
another one.
You can go in.
And you could also do device
orientation, how the device is
with the alpha, beta,
and gamma channel.
And there's a great article up
on HTML5 Rocks, if you want to
understand how those
guys work.
One thing to keep in mind when
you think about that is all of
the alpha, beta, gamma
is how you would
normally hold the device.
So in some cases, I'd hold
my device like this.
But on a different device,
you might hold it like
this or like this.
So both of those are all things
that you need to take
into account for the device
orientation and
device motion stuff.
Finally, on here, you can see
the Emulate Touch Events.
So that's going to simulate
touch events and fire the
touch events at the same,
when I click on things.
So those are all available.
I think Device Orientation
is available in beta.
It's not available in the
stable channel yet.
So if you need to go
in and check, you
want try one of those.
Go have a quick peek in the in
the beta or even in the Dev or
Canary or even in the
Chromium Channel.
There's a couple of new ones
that are coming soon.
Let me pull up Chromium for a
sec because I think this one's
kind of neat.
So I'll bring up
Chromium here.
And I'll just go to google.com,
bring up the
developer tools.
Again, same thing, go click
on the little guy here.
And under overrides, I now also
have Emulate CSS Media.
So that I can go in and say,
hey, in this particular case,
I want you to pretend that
I'm a print device.
And I want you to show me what
the page is going to look
like, if you're applying
the print style.
Rather than having to go hit
print every single time to see
what it looks like and look in
the print preview, you can
just go apply that
print style.
Maybe you want to go to use a
different one, like screen or
projection or something
like that.
You can go see how all
of those look.
So easy way to go do this--
and if you're ever curious
about what's coming and what's
down the pike, always check
out Chromium.
My general recommendation, if
you're sort of looking to stay
on the edge, but you want
something pretty stable.
And you want to be
able to test some
of the newer features.
It's to install Chrome Beta or
Chrome Stable as your primary
browser experience and then
install either Chrome Canary
or Chromium itself.
And that way, you'll always
have the latest.
You'll always have
the greatest.
You can see what's going on
in the fun new stuff.
And you can see what's
going on in the
stable, regular thing--
how most of your users are
going to see things.
I personally like
to go with beta.
So that way, I'm a little
bit ahead of the curve.
And if the bug gets introduced
on something or maybe
something changes, I'm going to
see it before my users are.
And that, to me, is
really important.
I want to know about these
things before my users do
because I want to make sure
that I've got a great
experience.
So a bunch of great
Chrome dev tools--
there's a bunch of great
sessions available on Google
Developer Live that go into much
more depth on how to use
some of these dev tools.
I just sort of wanted to give
you a good introduction to do
a couple of these things.
So let's move on to the
next one and talk
about some of the emulators.
Emulators are a great way to
get an idea of how things
might work.
Is it going to behave how you
expect it to behave in the
native environment?
Now again, you're not going to
get the exact performance
characteristics.
And there are some things
that may or may
not work in the emulator.
For example, the camera doesn't
work in the emulator
for most of these devices.
But it does work in
other places.
So it does work on the device.
But most other things work.
So there's a few places where
this is a good way
to go and do this.
So there's a couple of good
emulators available.
There's the Android emulator,
which I've got linked there.
It's a quick, easy
thing to install.
It's not exactly the
fastest thing.
But it's pretty decent.
And it does give a fair
representation.
If you install Xcode, you can go
and get the iOS simulators,
which will give you the iPhone
and iPad, the iPhone
5, the iPhone 4.
In fact, it'll give
you quite a few.
Let me bring up one of
the iOS simulators.
So when I bring up the
iOS simulator, sure
enough, here we go.
We've got Safari running
right now.
Let me make this a little
bit smaller, so that
it's nice and small.
Here we go.
So you can see that I've
got Safari on here.
I can start Safari.
It starts up pretty quick.
If I go to type in here, I can
go click on this and type
HTML5rocks.com.
It just uses my network
connection to go pull this
stuff down, shows me
exactly as I would
expect things to be.
So in this particular case--
and it also responds
to touch events.
So in order to scroll, what I
have to do is go click on the
page and then scroll up.
So I've got that sort of real
experience, as I'd expect it
to behave on a true device.
If I go back up to the top and
I want to go search here, I
can click on in here.
And if I wanted to type-- so
I said device orientation.
You can see this would take me
forever-- device orientation.
So sure enough, I go
click on that.
I should get some
results here.
And sure enough, here's that
device orientation article
that I was talking
about earlier.
So we can go through, scroll,
and see all the stuff that
we're looking for.
So there's a good, easy
way to be able to
go in and test this.
You can switch between
different hardware.
So you can change from the iPad
to the iPad Retina to an
iPhone, whatever you're
looking to test.
That same is true for
Android as well.
You can try different devices.
You could try different
characteristics on those
devices, whether they have a
keyboard, whether they don't
have a hardware keyboard--
so quick easy way to be able
to go in and do these guys.
So let's go back to our
slides here and
continue on from here.
The other one that's worth
checking out is Browser Stack.
Browser Stack is a great tool
that you give it a link to
your site, and it'll go render
it in several different
browsers and give you
the screen shots.
And in fact, I believe on this
one even gives you access to
the DOM, which is
pretty slick.
Because you can go in, and you
can try seeing how things
behave in the DOM.
But emulators are
only so good.
We want to be able to test
these on real devices,
understand how these are going
to behave in a real scenario.
So let's have a look at
how you'd use one
of the remote debuggers.
And actually, we'll have
a look at a couple
of the remote debuggers.
You can do remote debugging with
Chrome for Android on an
Android device.
You can do with us Safari
on iOS 5 and Safari 6.
And you can actually do
it on Firefox as well.
And I've got all the slides
that walk you through the
instructions on how
to do this.
And you can follow
the instructions
along on your own.
So for Android, the first thing
you've got to do is--
on all of these, there's a
one-time set-up experience.
You have to go set a few things
up, turn debugging on,
that kind of thing.
So for Android, we need
to install the
debugger for the SDK first.
Once we've done that on our
mobile device, we need to
enable USB debugging
at the OS level.
If you've got a phone that has
not ever gone into developer
mode before, you're going to
have to go through clicking--
I think it's you click on the
About Phone Settings like
seven times.
And that brings it up.
If you can find the developer
USB Developer Options in the
Settings menu, just
a quick search.
You'll find it pretty quickly.
Once you've got that done, we
need to open up Chrome and we
need to enabled the web debugger
within Chrome.
So once you've done all
that basic stuff--
I've already done all that
stuff on my device.
Let me bring up the
device down here.
So I've got my device.
And I'm going to
unlock it here.
So let's bring up Chrome.
And so we'll go to
HTML5 Rocks.
I'm just going to
grab my phone--
so HTML5 Rocks.
And this will take a
second and load.
Let me zoom this in just a
little bit, so you can see
this a little bit better.
All right.
So now that we've got this,
there's a couple of things
that we need to do.
On our desktop, I'm
going to come out.
And we need to run
ADB forward.
Now, I have this set
up as a script.
So I'll just show you
what my script says.
So you can see here it's adb
forward tcp 9222 and then
local abstract.
I recommend just having a
little script to do this
because it's a heck of a lot
easier than it is to go and
remember that all the time.
But what this does is it
connects through my USB port
to my device and allows me
to do remote debugging.
So I'll do Clank Debug.
It's gone and run.
So now, when we go back
to Chrome, let's
go open a new tab.
And we'll go to local
host colon 9222.
So at this point, we get two
windows that pop up.
So we've got the Mobile Web
Developer Toolkit and the
HTML5 Rocks.
So when I click on this, it
opens up the dev tools, just
like I'm used to seeing
on my computer.
But this is now showing
everything
on the mobile device.
Now, I've got the standard
resources, so I can go see all
the files that have
been pulled down.
I can go.
And if we reload this page-- so
let me go hit reload here--
you can see all of the network
requests coming in.
So we could see how everything
is going.
We can see all the scripts
that got pulled down.
So if I go and click and say,
OK well, let's see what this
script looks like.
OK, lots of great
stuff in here.
The timeline to understand
what's going on--
again, all the stuff that you're
used to being able to
use and see within the Chrome
Developer Tools are all
available here for
you, right now.
So in particular, what I want to
go do is show you a couple
of things in here.
Because it behaves just like
it does on your desktop.
I can go in.
And sure enough, notice how
in the actual device, as I
highlight through different
portions, if I go and expand
my header, so there is
that hyperlink there.
I can go through.
And I want to actually go, and
let's find where the main
content is here.
So I think my main content is--
where are we going here--
content.
There we go.
I think that's our content.
OK, so div--
I'm going to expand this out.
And so there's that.
So now, we could start going
through and finding all of the
different pieces that we want.
And we can go through and
change these things.
So I'm having a hard
time finding this.
I always love going for these
kinds of things--
live sessions.
Let's go up to Nav, Unordered
List, expand this.
And instead of it saying Home,
let's say Pete was here.
And sure enough, if we go have
a look at our page--
well, we're replacing
those with images.
So of course it's not
going to show that
particular right now.
But let me try.
Let me see if I can get
a different one.
I'm pretty sure it won't work.
But Pete was here.
Yeah, there we go.
All right, so we've
got Pete was here.
So you can go through.
You can change all the things
that you'd expect to normally
be able to change, within the
Chrome Developer Tools.
Nice, easy way to be able to go
in, understand what's going
on, and build your website, your
web application, without
too many things.
You can apply styles.
Now, the one thing to keep in
mind, this is being served
from the developer tools
on the device.
So you are getting the Device
Developer Tools.
So currently, this is Chrome
that's available in the
marketplace.
It's Chrome 18.
So you're only going
to have the
standard Chrome 18 features.
So if I go down here and I bring
up my settings, I don't
have the ability to be able
to change my UA string.
Actually, yes I do have
the ability to
change my User Agent.
But I don't have the ability to
be able to go and change my
device metrics or anything
like that.
Now, obviously, it would be a
little weird change the device
metrics on something that's
already a little tiny, but one
of those things you may or may
not want to do at some point
in the future.
Certainly, setting geolocation
is something that's
interesting and that you might
want to be able to do.
So with that, let's
get out of here.
So that's the Chrome
remote debugging.
It give you easy access to be
able to go through and debug
Chrome, remotely.
Let's take a look at how
you'd do Safari, on iOS
6 and on the iPad.
So again, very similar, there's
an initial set of set
up that you're going to
need to go through.
And I'm going to just switch
out some devices here.
So that I can plug-in
an iPad in.
And we can get this connected.
Now, again, one of the key
things that you need to be
aware of is that it does that
same thing where it needs to
be connected directly
to your device.
So you need to plug-in
via USB.
And your device is connected.
So now, let me bring
up our device.
So we can see what's
going on here.
So here we go.
We've got we've got my device.
And the set up settings are
pretty much the same.
We need to go through, and in
Safari, on our iPad or on our
iPhone, we need to enable the
Advanced Settings, so that we
can go in and actually
see what's going on.
But we also need to, on our
computer, go and to turn those
things on as well.
So that we've got them
set up there as well.
So sure enough, I've got my
iPad up and working here.
So you can see that we've
got everything running.
And so now, very similarly,
we're going
to do the same thing.
So I'll start up Safari.
And we'll come out
of the slides--
and Safari.
Great, so Safari comes up just
as we would normally expect.
I'll make this full screen,
so that we can see
everything going on.
Here we go.
And what I'm going to do is
go to the Develop Menu.
And you'll notice that your
device shows up, in the
Develop Menu.
So I go and click Pete's iPad.
And it shows me all of the tabs
that are currently open.
So I can go and click
on HTML5 Rocks.
And sure enough,
there it goes.
We've got my page up,
open, and ready
for me to start debugging.
Now, these are the Safari
developer tools.
So if you're used to using
those, you've got the ability
to be able to do all of the
things that you'd expect to be
able to do.
And notice, as you start going
through these things, you get
that same experience.
So let me just bring this down,
so that we can see this
a little bit better.
And I'm going to zoom in just a
little bit more, so that we
can see this.
So again, same thing,
I'll open up the
header, open up my Nav.
And again, here's my
unordered list.
And Posts and Tutorials--
I'll change this.
Pete was here.
And sure enough, can
we see that there?
There you go.
So it says Pete was here.
So you've got that same set of
tools, same set of abilities,
to be able to go in and do
remote debugging as you'd
expect to be able to do.
So this is a really great way to
understand what's going on
with the experience.
How are things working?
Is something going a
little bit weird?
Is something maybe not acting
like it you'd expect it to?
Is it pulling down
different data?
On this device as well, you do
have the ability to be able to
get in and turn on the Network
Link Conditioner.
Let me see if I can find that
real quick and show you guys.
But it's under Settings and
under the Developer Tools.
I'll see if I can find
this here real quick.
Of course, I'm not going
to be able to find it.
Well, I didn't plan
on showing this.
I was thinking about it after
the fact and thought it might
be kind of cool to show.
But I don't see it.
So I won't show it today.
It is a way that you can be able
to go and set the things
that you want.
All right.
Well, you can trust me that
it is in here somewhere--
a quick, easy way to be able to
go in, set up the network
settings, and turn on the
particular things that you
might be looking to do.
So Firefox has the same set
up, or a similar set up.
One of the key differences on
the Firefox set up, that I
really appreciate in their
particular set up, is that you
don't necessarily need to
connect the device via USB.
You can actually do it
over the network.
So as long as both devices are
connected to the same network
and on the same subnet,
you can connect in.
Again, there's a bunch of set
up that you need to go to.
On the desktop, you're
going to need to
enable remote debugging.
And on the remote device
on your mobile--
either your phone, your tablet,
whatever you need to do--
you need to go and turn
on the debugger.
You need to turn on the local
debugger, set that to false,
so that it sends all
the connection out.
In fact, let's see if
we've got it set up.
Actually, I tried it
earlier today.
It didn't work.
I don't want to go
and try it again.
I think the reason it didn't
work is I just didn't have the
same subnet set up.
Or there's some kind of firewall
rules within our
subnet that prevents that
from happening.
Again, you can go check at the
link there, where you can see
how to get more instructions
on getting that set up.
But it's a pretty easy way to be
able to go through and see
how your experience
is going to work.
One of the other really
important ways that you can
test your devices and this is
something that is, I think,
super important.
And I really want to encourage
the community to go out and
participate and help with
these Open Device Labs.
But the concept behind an Open
Device Lab is to have a space
where anybody can come in, test
their web application on
the variety of devices
that are out there.
When you think about the cost
of maintaining multiple
devices between all the
different versions, the
different operating systems, the
different sized screens,
the different processors, all
of a sudden that becomes a
pretty complex and almost
nightmarish experience to do.
And so to be able to go through
and use something like
an open device lab where there's
just tons of devices
available, and not just the
latest and greatest devices,
but also older devices that have
been around for a little
while or devices that are newer
but have the original
version of their operating
system on them.
So having those open
device labs are a
really fantastic thing.
If you have spare devices you're
not using anymore,
donate them to your
local device lab.
Or if you're in an area where
there's not an open device
lab, start one.
Find some folks.
Find a location where you can
help start your own open
device labs.
There's a great blog post here
that talks about all of the
open device labs, as well as
where you can go to find them,
as well as how to
start your own.
There's a couple here.
There's one that's just
starting in Brooklyn.
We're trying to get one
started in Manhattan.
There's one in San Francisco,
I believe,
just getting started.
There's one in Oakland.
We need these all
over the place.
We need these are all around the
world, so that developers
have a place where they can go
and test their applications,
where you can go,
where I can go.
Because I don't have
every device.
And I'm sure you don't either.
And you probably don't
want to maintain all
those devices either--
crazy, crazy amounts of
work to go do that.
So with that, I've got a couple
of favors to ask before
I start taking some
of your questions.
I will just bring up slides so
that you can have a look.
If you've got questions, you
can post them there to that
Google short link.
And I'll take your questions
here in a minute.
But we need your help.
We can't accept the status
quo with web development.
It just simply doesn't
work anymore.
And we need developers to really
push the limits of
what's cool, of what's
available, and
just do cool stuff.
If you're building something,
don't accept
that, oh, it's mobile.
So it's kind of going
to be slower.
It's going to suck.
Don't accept that.
That's not a good answer.
Go build awesome for the web.
If you find bugs, if you find
things that don't work as you
expect them in Chrome for
Android, tell us about them.
We want to hear about them.
You can go File bugs
at new.mcrbug.com.
Also, go there.
Have a look to see what bugs
are already filed, and star
the things that you think
are important.
Do you think it's important that
there's an ability to be
able to hide the address bar?
There's a bug for that.
Go star that if you think
that's important.
Reliable viewport control,
there's a bug for that.
We've got lots of bugs
filed already.
And we want your help to make
sure that we're making Chrome
for Android the best browser
that it can be.
If you're building cool stuff,
tell us about it.
When we launched Chrome a number
of years ago, one of
the things that we did was
launch Chrome Experiments,
which was sort of this
playground for people showing
off the cool stuff that
they built on the web.
Well, when we launched Chrome
for Android back in June, we
wanted to say to developers,
show us the cool stuff you're
doing on the mobile web.
Show us cool.
And it's a great place where you
can show the rest of the
world all the cool stuff
that you're doing
with the mobile web.
So build some cool mobile
experiments that work great on
mobile devices, that take
advantage of the unique
capabilities of a mobile
device-- maybe touch, maybe
device orientation, maybe
multi-touch--
but works beautifully on that
small screen and just is an
awesome experience.
Show us those things.
Show off your skills.
Show it off to your friends.
Do neat stuff.
Start an open device lab in
your area, if you haven't
started one.
Or you haven't seen
one in your area.
Or you think it's important.
Go do it.
We'd love to have
more of these.
It's really important to get
these out, to get access to
these devices.
So that we can build more cool
stuff and make sure it works
on the plethora of devices
that are out there.
But really, the mobile web is
what you and I make it.
We have an opportunity to
build absolutely cool.
We have the ability to
do amazing stuff.
And it's up to as web developers
to go do it.
So don't accept the
status quo.
Go build cool.
So with that, I'll open it
up to your questions.
I've seen already one question
in our moderator, as well as a
bunch of other places.
These slides are available
if you want.
Let me get rid of this guy here
for a sec so that you can
see the slides.
But the slides are available.
It's always kind of
fun to do this.
I do this a little backward.
See the slide link
is right there.
Yes, so the slide link
You can go check out these
slides yourself, as well you
can watch last week's session,
where we talked about some of
the libraries and other stuff
that is important for mobile
web developers.
I'm going to be back in the new
year, doing more stuff for
mobile, talking about High DPI,
multi-touch, all sorts of
stuff that really is relevant
to the mobile web developer.
If you're building for the
mobile web, you want to tune
into these sessions.
We'll try and do them at least
monthly, if not more.
Because there's a lot of really
great stuff out there.
So with that, I'll take
your questions.
Pop this guy up, and let's
just go to me.
So you get a nice, big
picture of me.
So one of the first questions
that I've got--
during my session last week,
I'm just reading it off the
screen here.
"During session one, you
mentioned to avoid relative
and absolute positioning.
Why?
Can you explain a little
bit about that?"
Yeah, absolutely.
Relative and absolute
positioning on a mobile device
can be used.
But you need to use
them with caution.
Because when you start thinking
about, I want to move
this div, for example, over 600
pixels, on a mobile device
that's maybe only
320 pixels wide.
You're going to move
it off screen.
So as you think about using
absolute and relative
positioning, you need to be very
careful that you're not
using pixels, but instead of
using either percents or--
there's a new unit that
you can use--
I don't think it's landed
everywhere.
I think it's only landed
in a couple of places.
But Viewport width--
so you can actually say, 1% of
the Viewport width, I want to
move it over.
So you can move a
div or element
over a specific amount.
So as you think about using
absolute and relative
positioning, just think in
terms of the size of the
screen that you're working on.
So I guess I should have
been a little bit
more clear last week.
It's really about being careful
and not moving stuff
over that will show
up off screen.
Because it may just show up in
the wrong place, may not even
show up on the device anymore.
So the next question
that we've got is--
what's going on with Chrome
for Android for--
"What's going on for
Chrome for Android?
Are we going to see another
release this year?
Are we going to get more
developer tools, like some of
the stuff you showed
us earlier?"
So that's a great question.
The end team is working on
trying to get sort of feature
parity between the mobile and
desktop version, get us to the
same version.
On desktop right now, I think
we're running 24 or 25.
On mobile, we're only at 18.
When they started working
on Chrome for Android.
They had to do a fork to the
code, to be able to make some
changes and all that.
They're almost done, if they
haven't already finished
integrating all those
changes back to the
main Chromium tree.
Now that's done, they're going
to be able to go through.
And we'll be able to see,
hopefully, more frequent
releases soon.
I don't have a date for you on
when we're going to see the
next release.
I've got my fingers crossed
that we're going to see it
really soon.
But I'm not going to hold my
breath on the specific date or
tell you a specific
date because I'm
not really 100% sure.
We want to make sure
we get this right.
We want to make sure that we're
giving you the right set
of tools and the right set of
resources that you need.
So that looks like that's the
end of the questions.
I want to say thank you guys
so much for joining us, or
joining me.
It was a great session,
I think, today.
I hope you learned a lot.
Be sure to check out session
number one, so that you see
some of the stuff
that's going on.
My name's Pete LePage and
thanks for joining me.
I hope you have a really
great holiday.
And we'll see you next year.